whatever happened to Baby Shaq the Greek
phenomenon who even went up against the
real Shaquille O'Neal sofo was drafted
back in 2003 by the Los Angeles Clippers
coming in at 6'10 and 345 lb but there's
a reason why people called him baby Shaq
Shaq was listed at 7'2 and 354 lb at the
time sofo gained so much attention that
Shaq took it personally and what
happened in their preseason matchup back
in 2009 would be a rude awakening for
him Shaq who was with the Cav dropped an
easy 12 points while sofo struggled with
just four that preseason game turned out
to be the highlight of his NBA career
because he never played in the league
but even though that didn't work out for
him his accomplishments at the domestic
level are still spectacular he was still
a dominant force in the Euro league
being a five-time Greek Allstar and even
won silver at the feeo world
championship in 2016 so although he
never became the next biggest European
star in the NBA he still one of the best
Internationals